thank you by data for hosting us and
actually allowing us to be one of the
corporate sponsors for the conference of
course we do it with a reason we want to
recruit the best we want to hear the
best we want to see the best but right
now we will talk about as you can see in
the lower left corner we have JP Morgan
there so it is a bank and we'll talk
about how to manage Python at large
scale without breaking the bank so I'll
talk to you about first a little bit
about JP Morgan and Athena I think
there's a platform that runs in one of
the parts of JP Morgan and it is a
Python based platform so I'll describe
to you what that is
we'll talk about some of the objectives
that we have in our ecosystem we'll talk
about continuous delivery conceptually
and we'll also look at how we do this
under the hood then we'll talk a little
bit about challenges with dealing with a
large Python based ecosystem both from
the point of view of how we manage it
and from the point of view of a
challenges of dealing with open source
software and we use a lot of open source
and in the end we'll finish with some
conclusions and hopefully a good Q&A
session and hopefully this will work all
right
so JPMorgan I don't think it needs a lot
of introduction so I'll briefly run
through the numbers one of the world's
biggest banks trillions of dollars in
assets almost hundred billions in
revenue producing trillions of payments
every day and millions and millions of
transactions every day we are really
large company with 230,000 employees all
over the world at the same time we're
also one of the world's biggest
technology companies and this is a
pretty massive scale we have over 40,000
technologists working for the bank and I
would hope and I would imagine a lot of
them are developers not necessarily
Python developers but developers in
different different languages Kabal is
probably not the most popular one even
though some people view banks as still
being an incredible stage we do massive
investment in technology almost ten
billion dollars here every year and this
technology investments pay off we that
makes us one of the world's biggest
banks and one of the more successful
ones now lets me jump from JP Morgan to
Athena Athena has been envisioned just
over ten years ago as a cross line of
business within the investment bank
Python based pricing trading risk
management analytics platform with tools
for data science and machine learning
now to be honest the data science and
machine learning the conference
organizers asked me to add at the end
because they said if you don't add
machine learning to your presentation
you're not allowed in you know in this
in this organization so I had to add it
seriously though we are actively working
on multiple machine learning projects
and actually if you step out
side to our booth we have a number of
guan's also attending this conference
who are very actively building machine
learning packages we have a data science
team which is using a lot of this
packages was in Athena environment and
outside of it as well and we are also
actively looking for more people to
contribute so we have thousands of users
across multiple lines of businesses
credit effects rates their mortgages
equities there is a very wide user base
for the Athena platform we have 1,500
Python developers who not only use the
platform to develop code within the
platform but also to contribute to the
platform itself the whole platform works
as a internal open source project so you
can see the entire code base and you can
contribute it very very easily over the
years of course it we have built out a
very large number of Python modules of
150,000 Python modules sort of last
count 35 millions lines of Python code
all living in a single repository I'll
talk about it a little later we use
massively as I mentioned open source
over 500 plus packages from the open
source community and our philosophy is
to enable developers to deploy very
quickly and develop very efficiently so
that they can impact the business very
very rapidly so a little bit more about
Athena and its technical foundation we
build a lot of stuff ourselves and a lot
of things have been built and before
similar concepts existed in the open
open-source community or we're stable
and reliable enough to use so we built
our own globally replicated object store
called Hydra we built a complex event
processor you can think of it as a
reactive data data
the graph which we use for streaming
events and streaming trades and
connecting to exchanges and all kinds of
other streaming analytics we have a
pixie graph which is essentially a lazy
evaluation dependency graph which allows
us to run efficiently complex analytical
calculations where some dependencies
change and some dependencies don't a
typical example of that are risk
scenarios where some market data changes
in some doesn't so we only recalculate
what needs to be recalculated and keep
around what doesn't change we have
number of frameworks for thick client
deployments Athene application framework
for the web deployments we use the
modern tools that are available in the
in the web ecosystem we build our own
job scheduler which runs on thousands of
compute nodes scheduling around 270
thousand jobs daily with over 1 million
processors running daily and we
integrate those internal compute grid
which is sort of a predecessor of a
cloud technologies which has hundreds of
thousands of compute cores and GPUs so
that allows us to run massive scale
calculations so all of this runs on a
single Python based platform with some
underlying c++ components for for the
foundation so what are our objectives
well of course the primary objective is
keeping users and clients happy that's
that's a goal at the same time we need
to ensure robust Ness and stability of
our production systems and keep
developers productive and efficient
because that also makes developers happy
and that's important otherwise they
leave we need to provide Kwan's and data
scientists with quality tools for doing
research and these days machine learning
and data science so that's another
important aspect of it and at the same
time we want to encourage
and global consistency across business
lines we don't want different lines of
businesses have a different idea of what
an option pricing is or how a market
date is represented because that way
they will end up reinventing the wheel
over and over again so we want to be
able to actually share and reuse those
components so well now let's take a look
at how we approach those objectives one
of the primary concepts in Athena is a
concept of continuous delivery we are
actually able to change production code
thousands times a day
I just ran some stats last night and
added this to the slide and we actually
do 10,000 to 15,000 production changes
every week in our Python code base this
is massive so how do we keep at the same
time production safe and stable is a
challenging task we also want the full
visibility of the entire code base one
reason for that is everyone can
contribute people can move from one line
of business - xur and still be very
familiar with the entire code base and
how everything works people can share
knowledge and share code base and share
Python modules we also need something
that is allows us to deploy our code
into production globally and instantly
we want the same risk model to run in
Tokyo as we're running in New York or in
London so it is also one of the
important underpinning cornerstones of
ofagina
what do we use under the hood and this
is very brief of course under the hood
we actually use Hydra which is as I
mentioned earlier our globally
distributed object store and we not only
use Hydra for data but we also use it
for code because code is nothing more
than
a file which is data so having this
replicated globally replicated object
store allows us to have code instantly
available around the globe to address a
sharing of the code we have the entire
code base in one large Moana repository
and even though lately the ways of
storing code using git and other other
version control systems became more and
more popular you can and I will actually
in the end will reference paper by
Google how they also use a single
repository for storing billions of lines
of their code and of course all of this
relies on the extensive automated
testing so the pipeline for continuous
delivery is actually ridiculously simple
you write some code you write some files
you write some tests for that for your
code then you test your commit and the
point when you commit we also run
another set of tests just to make sure
that what you're committing is actually
consistent you need not just allowing
you to test somewhere on the side and
then go on and commit a file and while
you commit we do other checks as well we
do quality code quality check using
various lint options once you commit at
the file and you feel that it's ready
for production deployment actually you
as a developer fills that it's ready to
be pushed to production you change
something for a trader or you out meant
it something in the risk management
system or you change some other
component you asked for a bless and so
it's similar to a pull request
essentially you each file has a set of
people who can actually say hey this is
good so you send a message using
basically a button push on the I in your
IDE to say hey can you please review and
bless it and once somebody says hey your
changes are okay and I bless your
changes he actually takes 50% of
responsibility for this being correct so
you actually need to be careful what you
bless and not bless blindly why because
the moment you bless this file can
anybody can automatically push the
production by button push and when I
mean it can be pushed to production it
will actually end up in the production
source code tree and any process that is
importing that file can actually import
that protists immediately anywhere
around the globe in any of the processes
so again we have 10,000 to 15,000
modules pushed the production every week
it's 2 to 3,000 today pretty large
amount and I'll skip pro's and con's
they're somewhat obvious time to market
of course and fear of change and
stability yes of course and we'll talk
about that so imagine you were a
developer and you came in to Athena and
you decided hey I want to write some
code you open your IDE and you have
immediate access to the entire mono
Reaper to the entire code base it looks
to you like a file system even though I
will mention later that we actually
store your files in a database so you
can look at the production files down at
the bottom and say you want to work on
the modules a B C and D and you want to
create a new module called e you can
create as many layers as you want and
those layers are essentially act as
staging areas so you open your
environment you read a file say B and
you want
to create a new version of it you create
a new version of it it immediately
becomes a member of your layers there is
no process of checking out a whole
repository there is no process of
pulling something in you actually
changing the file and the moment you hit
ctrl safe it will be saved in your local
staging area and you can layer those
staging areas who is essentially kind of
ICU like a visibility rule so the higher
layers overshadows the lower layers so
for example this particular developer as
module B 3 and C 2 and E 1 module B C
and E in his own environment of his
versions 3 - an E and when Juan and he
also is using some shared staging area
which multiple developers may be sharing
between themselves and all of this is
underpinned by a single production
source so for this particular developer
his view of the world is as described in
the lower line his effective runtime
will be picked of this particular
versions of files and it's not only for
this developer he can share this area
with anybody else in the bank so anybody
else in any region in the bank who uses
Athena can open against this set of
staging areas and see exactly the
changes that have been done at the same
time you can run any process on any of
the servers in the bank again if they're
part of the athena co system against
this set of staging areas and they will
execute exactly this collection of code
and of course we will not allow this
code to alter any production data so we
have fail-safes that only modules that
are already in the production ecosystem
will be allowed to touch and modify
production data so indeed what do we do
we instead of file system to store
modules and then do a check ins and
check out we use
Lulla replicated database to store files
and this globally replicated database
essentially syncs transactions
continuously between each other and they
form a ring so the file or any object
written in London will be almost
immediately up to the replication gap
available in New York in Tokyo in any of
the other databases that belong to the
that link ecosystem so we have a module
called leap foo which does something Li
bar and so on and so forth
we had to customize a Python importer
and to enable this capability to import
from the from the database but because
our database actually looks to the user
almost as a file system that wasn't a
very difficult task of course one may
ask if you are pushing to production so
many changes continuously how do you
keep your production processes stable
especially since you have one single
repository and in Python as we know you
know anything can import anything and
Dragons and dependencies and keep
dragging dependencies in so how do we
ensure that our mission-critical
production processes continue to run
while we keep pushing changes into the
system well we will take advantage
actually of the fact that we're storing
our files not in the file system but in
database where things are transactional
and they have time stamps and they have
a lot of other nice properties so we
will ask every owner of a production
based system to create something called
source marker and essentially what it is
it's a reference to a timestamp the
timestamp when you run all your
regression and unit tests and ensured
that the entire code base that you
depend on is actually good and for a
certain duration of time the entire
production system for this particular
application will use the specific time
slice
of the of the source database to to
actually protect him from accidental
rogue pushes to production by somebody
else unrelated overnight typically that
source marker will move because the
tests will run again and we run the test
continuously so if the tests run
successfully the source marker advances
and your next day job runs again against
a new code base which has been verified
if it didn't you will get alerted and
you will have time to actually change
you change your code or work with the
developer who did the did the breakage
because you will remain on the older
source marker so that ensures the
production stability while pushing a lot
of changes simultaneously into the
system what's running underneath so I
mentioned a lot of C++ based components
and open source components which we rely
on so at the top you see our massive
Python source which is our massive mono
repository of everything running in
Python underneath we have more
traditional development where C++ and
open source binaries are involved this
is your typical two-week cycle of build
compile deploy underpinning
infrastructure that including the
database itself including the software
development lifecycle components and all
the other components as well the prod in
the center is our current production
approved system and it's deployed
globally tools servers the prod new is
your typical release candidate that
keeps changing continuously until the
log down time before it will become the
next prod and the product is kept for
safety in case we didn't reduce some
incompatibility into the system we
can always fall back some of the jobs
some of the critical jobs on product and
they're falling back and forth between
those components is a very trivial it
essentially flipping a symbolic link we
encourage strongly encourage all the
testing and all the development activity
to go against prod new this allows us to
actually validate the release candidate
before it becomes production and on top
of this encouragement we also run an
enormous amount of unit tests and
regression tests which automatically run
overnight and during the day on a
massive compute grid to ensure that the
system is holistically stable so now
let's talk about some of the challenges
of this of this environment I mentioned
that we have a high dependence on open
source packages so as you probably know
upgrading open source packages leads to
many challenges open source community is
not always great at maintaining api
compatibility so if you have a massive
investment in your meaning he miracle
stability and computations and risk the
risk numbers and reports to regulators
it's really really difficult to keep
adjusting to the API changes especially
for some newer packages changed of
changes to pickles and storage
representations well the great example
of this is pandas you move from one
version to the other if you happen to
store millions of data frames and some
database well that's a wrong idea but
quants love to do that in file systems
and in databases everywhere so now that
is really difficult to test because you
don't know when this is going that this
particular object is going to be read
but if you want to move your
entire ecosystem they're actually more
modern version you need to ensure that
it is somewhat compatible with with with
all stored representation numerical
changes that happens again all the time
just recently we've been working with an
umpire create an umpire upgrade and and
we discovered through again
rigorous testing that in one of the
interesting edge cases a covariance
matrix produced by some linear algebra
calculation using non P was not
perfectly symmetric well it was
symmetric up to a float point I'll
tolerance the previous version of numpy
had actually perfectly symmetric matrix
so one of the one of the tests was
actually testing a numerical equivalence
exactly instead of using the float point
tolerance so we actually run into this a
case where we saw that the result is
actually not perfect and then you need
to work of course with with the Kwan's
and with end-users to validate are we
still producing a correct number and
this is just one of the examples runtime
binary dependencies another example of
open source challenge that actually
happened that anecdote is happening
happened just the other day we had a
quant who had some program using numpy
and was calculating again some linear
algebra of course matrices and then he
decided hey I want to play with standard
flow info so he imported tender flow
into that into that same process and
suddenly numpy started producing wrong
results not crashing just producing
wrong results so he goes through
extensive search and you know on the
internet look what's happening and
apparently if you compile both numpy and
tensor flow is mkl support which is math
kernal library from intel you would run
into a specific problem which where each
of the each of the runtimes tries to
grab as many threads as possible in some
random things
it is true so besides open source source
package of grades what other challenges
do we face we do have limited branching
support in our massive mana repository
it actually works pretty well for
production use cases you want to keep
your changes small and fast and move
forward as soon as possible rather than
creating a massive branches of different
projects and then have painful merges
it's also quite difficult to have one
large testing infrastructure if you have
multiple branches of your projects but
this doesn't fit some of the some of the
research and experimental workflows
where for example some researcher may
want to say ok I want to run several
very similar code bases in parallel and
so I may want to create several branches
of that so this is something what we we
are we're actually actively looking at
and trying to see how we can fit every
workflow that is needed for being
productive into the ecosystem and of
course it's very difficult to just
freeze the entire ecosystem for a fully
reproduce ability if you want to say I
want the entire platform to be frozen
and the next year I want to be able to
rerun exactly the same code we just keep
on moving forward so let me go to some
conclusions well pythons flexibility
makes things easier we can create custom
importers we can do some static code
analysis to do better testing and so on
and so forth good integration tests help
us with to ensure compatibility and
consistency between multiple packages
modules don't have to be loaded from a
file system yes we can load them from
database and take advantage of some of
the properties of a database production
stability the
employ slow delivery and slow deployment
we deploy thousands of packages while
keeping production stable so this is not
not a problem and open source of course
doesn't imply free
you still need to invest a massive
amount of testing and integration into
supporting open source packages and last
but not least shared platform
unfortunately doesn't imply shared
knowledge you have a shared platform
with the entire code base visible but
people will still reinvent the will will
write their own well because their
developers they like to develop and that
not how it happens or maybe they don't
trust somebody else developing the code
just a couple of references at the end
please visit us on the website or visit
us at our booth right outside if you're
interested either in the technology
aspect of what you are doing or in the
data science and machine learning I will
say this words again aspect of what you
are doing because our Kwan's
are really really hungry to have more
people working with them on these
problems and a motivation for emulating
code base is feel free to check out this
I don't know how you can click on it
right now but it's pretty easy to find
why Google stores billions of lines of
code in a single repository you can find
this offline for motivation and do I
have time for Q&A perfect yes
thank you you had quoted a number I
think 10 billion annual spend on your
technology budget what percentage of
that would you say goes towards hardware
and software and on the software side
what portion of that goes towards
internal developer salary versus
third-party licensing I'll be I'll be
very honest with you that I don't have
that breakdown but if you stop by our
booth we can definitely talk about that
and discuss that and III can come with
some estimates but since I'm recorded I
will probably not it's it's nice Google
style interview question right so I will
not embarrass myself trying to estimate
it my guess is a very large component
goes to salaries people are still a very
expensive commodity so we actually want
to find good people who are usually a
little bit more expensive but a little
more when you do have to make something
reproducible for example for a
regulatory relevant run how do you
achieve that
100% reproducibility right that's a very
very good question and a hundred percent
is usually a target really a wishful
target to hit I would like to separate
in terms of reproducibility the code the
model and the data so having the data
represented in such a way that you can
actually reproduce what happened is
extremely critical one of the answers to
the regulator's is they don't have you
don't have to rerun something as long as
you have it already available as a
result of your calculations you may be
able to just return that so if you have
a correct correctly structured by
temporal store
you should be able to have a capability
to actually reproduce it from already
save data you don't have to execute
exactly the same binary code to get that
so that would be one of the ways to get
the right numbers and the right
calculations and not you know run
exactly the same binary and of course
models are very thoroughly governed so
we have for the quantitative models for
the critical models we have governance
groups who actually look at the fact
that your model continues to perform
correctly they have ongoing ongoing
performance assessments and so on so so
we have ways to actually ensuring that
the results that we produce are still
consistent while we may be able well we
may be running a different version of a
code so obviously a data scientist is
not quite a software engineer and a
software engineer is not quite a data
scientist so say you have like a data
science use case right you're trying to
predict something your data scientist is
working out what the best model is and
is developing a script to execute
against whatever it is you're doing I
guess my question for you is it and I'll
eat a data science program at a small
cut smaller company like then what
you've got your solution developed
you're ready to you have something that
looks like production I guess how does
JP Morgan handle the situation who
maintains the code who writes the tests
actually we try to have and I don't know
if that's the right way or the wrong way
but this is the way we do it is our
quants and currently they are the main
data scientists actually write the code
and write the tests and they integrate
with components and we we try that's why
we actually built out this large
ecosystem to relieve them of the
to arrive beta cleaning routines or
adapters to various databases so all the
foundational framework is already there
you should write your model hopefully as
a quant you're a smart person you can
write reasonable code as well and have
tests around it all the Kwan's are
developers as well at the same time and
then you essentially can have this model
both developed in the environment tested
in their environment and deployed in the
environment so you're not essentially
changing you're not taking some abstract
model developed in one language and then
giving it to a developer hey please can
you interpret that into a different
language which leads to all kinds of all
kinds of challenges so obviously
building a system like this comes with
some design considerations that are
taken into account that kind of puts you
on a road that you know everything has
to be compliant so is the paradigm that
you subscribe to that everything has to
be backwards compatible so like once you
put something into the system it will
work forever or is there a you know
versioning we're actually actually it's
almost our way around we we try to move
the whole ecosystem forward so it's a
fixed forward rather than fall backward
methodology so then just so how does
that work in practice the things just
like fall off as they stop working or no
they don't stop working well if they
become irrelevant they stop working and
you delete the code hey hooray we
deleted some code this is awesome but if
they're actually needed for for
production well we have teams that
support that codebase if you want to
move the whole train forward these teams
help to move the rest of the platform
forward and adjust so if we do release
and we do have so it's a trade off as
you as you correctly pointed out and the
trade of all is for example do I want to
20 teams running let's say for example
each of them running at different pandas
in different numpy and then managing
that deployment or do I want all the
teams be on a single or say two versions
I probably actually as for efficiency
again going back without breaking the
bank for the efficiency for the
consistency I would love all of them to
be living on the same version and
marching forward so we do have to move
things forward rather than keep them
deep deeply backwards-compatible know if
that answers the question a lot yeah we
can we can chat after any more questions
hey what did the methods used to prevent
reinventing the wheel how do
Kwan's find other code is there okay
sometimes you cannot prevent it and that
will actually even tell you a little
anecdote I to write a function that you
know chunks a list or an iterable into
you know fixed size components and first
test and I thought well that this is a
very cool and easy function to write and
that will you know just because I like
writing code I'll just tried those few
lines and write them correctly and then
I decided well how about I first you
know use our internal search tool of
glimpse to see you know if somebody
already wrote something which looks like
chunka chunka phi or something like that
so I decided how I did glimpse def junk
I found hundred forty-five instances
some of them were incorrect some of them
were exact copies of the others
of them were correct but would take an
extra argument which limit their I know
you know capability or will alter their
behavior so yes it's a very very very
very very valid question at the same
time we have full visibility of the code
so if you probably will search for you
know volatility you will find you know
all the code which is related to
constructing volatility surfaces and
then you can drill down and see who
developed that what the history of the
changes are you can you know reach out
to that person and say hey I see you
build this how can I use this the next
step would be actually building and
that's what I was in my team and
actually a couple of people from my team
is sitting right there we're trying to
build out essentially a knowledge base
or knowledge repository which will help
Kwan's and data scientists at the higher
level define what their to doing and
make this metadata more easily
searchable so that you can actually
share knowledge at a higher level my
Jupiter notebooks who are some website
or some other interactions thank you
very much everyone thank you Mesa
[Applause]